this is SCP containment this is SCP
containment brunch
this is SCP containment branch this is
SCP containment breach the original game
that was made a long time ago has
finally been updated and it started to
be updated quite a bit recently it's
come out with regular updates and I
think it's because like SCP unity
started like getting popular and the
remake of that and then the original
creators or people like that we're like
hey we did that and so like they're
finally updating its still free which is
still shocking to me like geyser makes
money funny anyway we're gonna get into
it we're gonna start right from the
beginning I'm gonna disable the intro
sequence because that's not gonna be any
different my name is Mark so if you're
ready I'm ready let's go in
the old familiar sounds familiar smells
oh hi Hey look out behind you I'm gonna
save your apparently [ __ ] oh yeah I
remember this they added this in yeah
it's pretty loud I'm gonna close this oh
no I'm gonna close that we're simple
never mind I'm not going to close it
there are beers to be locked okay the
volume still good Oh
[Applause]
immediately immediately you say I know
about hey [ __ ] off with that [ __ ] you -
I'm gonna go over there I'm gonna slap
the [ __ ] out of you when I find you
present that ass I will slap a simple
man I see an ass I slap so is SCP
shooby-dooby down here whoa Oh lamp got
scared by it lamp hello are you looking
at me no okay so this is largely gonna
be the same I didn't read the changelog
in depth but it did say that there was
like new versions of the ending new bug
fixes new stuff like bad things that
could be addressed before I seems new
though but I thought there was something
here that I could used before so I'm
just gonna explore it for a long period
of time they also did some optimism that
that cos doc button bye-bye [ __ ]
forgot about you I knew that was I knew
that was gonna be a thing I knew it I
knew that I was well aware that that was
gonna be a thing I've seen that before
what whoa whoa hey whoa whoa whoa
there's a lot more going on here than I
remember or maybe there's not but either
way you all need to calm the [ __ ] down
what you doing over there okay okay
there's a Tesla gate I can get through
that but let's see if I need to first oh
god why is my mouse like breaking on me
hello oh oh oh that's not right I can't
oh I'm very drunk
I'm extremely high I can't look to the
right very goodly let me make sweet love
to my mouth is how you make sweet love
right okay
I'll be better know something just don't
want me looking looking around very hard
oh I don't know what's happening I can't
move
oh hey well nevermind then wait like
something I'm a mouse smoothing kind of
make that lower Wow ah what's my friend
frame limit nice 60 I don't know
oh okay that's a little better now that
I limited the frame rate that is a
little better that is in fact a little
better okay so he's coming that way oh
never mind
oh [ __ ] dude I didn't why did you lady
good wait hang on who shot she was
talking to me
listen right
easy enough
ooh this is I don't remember any of this
I feel like it's doing a lot more than
it was before you know what I mean I
feel like this game is doing
considerably more than it was in the
previous times that I've
okay well I can't go Chewbacca
wow I can't go through there without the
mask good honor the mask yet I don't
know dad I don't sound too good
maybe it's not so bad but you know you
know how it'd be with this game well use
dead use guys is dead and I'm not dead
there's gas masks wicked that's what I
was looking for level one card that's
good I needed that there's documentation
here but I don't think I need it I've
read all the documentation a million
times over why would I need it again
batteries take three just in case hey
hey okay I don't think there's anything
down there that I actually need I'm
pretty sure that's the layout plan you
don't actually think I remember someone
screaming but you know so many people
scream in this place how can you tell
one from another how could you ever tell
one from another okay I saved I think
this is the Nazi one if I'm not mistaken
this is the one where a bunch of Nazi
stuff happens so let's go experience
that because I feel like it
what about level one oh god damn it god
heck in heck yes hack God peace of heck
god damn it alright come back for that I
know how to get cards in this game maybe
this is an elevator I don't want to go
down in the elevator because that sounds
bad so I'm not gonna go in once I have
to close that for now I'm gonna try to
go through this area over here there's a
fuel aapke that's a checkpoint lockdown
can't go bare but that's where we need
to go for the next area I do have the
gas I've never seen a layout like [ __ ]
why is this [ __ ] what is this [ __ ] I've
never seen this [ __ ] before this is new
this is new Oh
report all potential income it's like a
deer shooting out of a recycling bin
little weird huh okay what does okay
just some weird checkpoint
don't forget today is pizza day oh [ __ ]
what is this if I can go through here it
is open what do I need for this one oh
it worked
dad dad I didn't expect that to actually
work what is this I've never oh oh you
let me close it behind me just in case I
just picked up I might as well put
everything in the clipboard
oh no no put the clipboard there there
we go okay pick up dumbass alright cool
now put a battery in dumb app okay cool
all right anyway some kind of storage
room that's awfully nice of them you're
not gonna have this oh I can finally get
a radio again which I haven't been yeah
I'm not trying to look at I'm trying to
drag it whatever that was I probably
knew about it
god I'm trying to drag these things [ __ ]
you know fit though there you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that well I was boring glad I did
that
ooh that is that's an SCP isn't it isn't
it isn't this actually an SCP I can't
run well it's gone now apparently
there's something about this origami
that's actually an SCP I can't I can't
remember about whatever okay I don't
need another car well I do need another
card in case I mess up this one I'll
take the extra battery and I've already
got a clipboard so just in case I mess
this up I'm gonna keep I'm gonna hold on
to that oh wow okay death by ear well
[ __ ] that doesn't sound good also I'm
all the way over here now so dick me
decked me right in the bunghole we gotta
go back I've never I've never actually
died in that little bear before
fascinating death III suppose the way
that one works if I recall correctly the
way that one works is it lets out a loud
shriek and then your body just starts
growing ears all over the skin
everywhere inside like every surface
area in inside and outside of your body
starts growing skins so like your throat
starts growing ears like your your your
everything your ears start growing ears
like you need to start growing ears it's
not it's not chill it ain't cool it it's
pretty much the opposite of chill and or
cool so yeah now I gotta say before I
die horribly the ears I'm gonna go back
on the same at the computer screen in
the Nazi room just in case cuz you never
know buddy here always close the doors
behind you or else you get knock upon by
dog big Billy
okay moving on
there's another way to go besides the
ear out oh but I do have the gas mask
let me go let me go down here first
because I bet this is gonna be more of a
are you sure about that we're all Gucci
here we're go to work goochie goochie
goo what do you need for good one whoa
wait a minute I know this is a trap I
know a trap when I say one yep there's
the trap I said oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
level two I want to drop that they got
that one
[Music]
ooh-la-la ela they deal with all these
okay oh all right we're all good I'm
gonna go in this room real fast like I
know how this work but I got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] save oh [ __ ] I can save it that
okay I don't know oh boy I can never
remember if it actually is really not
doesn't look like it is but hey we saved
so what's the worst that could happen I
die a horrible death
[Music]
hmm this game sure is good about making
you do things that you don't want to do
we haven't really encountered a lot of
new stuff I say as I enter in a new area
I've never seen before what is this
place buddy alright so I've got a I've
got a level two they're always blood
here I can't remember
probably so I'm gonna lock myself in
all right whatever can't carry any more
items well that's okay cuz I don't know
why I have two of these well I'm gonna
drop one in now for the map I'm gonna
try fine I'm gonna drop it in here and
try to make it a fine one there's very
few things that you need for very fine
as I remember I always found this one to
be the most fascinating SCP this machine
what did we get why'd we go I think we
got the ultimate version OS 310 oh is
that the ultimate I think that's the
ultimate what happens okay let me let me
put eyes since I have a spare let me put
this one in on ultra fine I don't know
if that's the correct answer but you
know it's the only answer I've got so
whatever
oh there's test logs put one chimp on
fine okay it made something I can't
carry any more of this let me put that
on a clipboard ah that's the ultimate
yeah well that don't that don't look
good but anyway I've got this so I don't
need that anymore the only problem is I
don't have a save point in here so I
can't exactly make take too many risks
but I've got one of these I'm gonna try
to I'm gonna try to put this to Omni
[ __ ] was it fine or very fine right so
they've changed up how this works good
thing I looked at this otherwise I would
have been doing this forever you can get
all up to a level 3 card by putting a
level 2 in there and going to fine if
you go to level 2 and you crunch it on
fine
it has a chance to go to level 3 but
then level 3 is gonna be the max that I
can get
once I get to level 4 I can may turn a
level 4 into a level 5 and then I can
turn a level 5 into Omni oh [ __ ] I have
a chance to front a level 5 into a
nominee but this is my level 3 so that's
good I'm gonna create two level threes
whoa why would I need two level threes
right I'm gonna leave this here then cuz
I'm pretty sure this is good for now
there's also the gas mask and then the
only other thing is the radio but I
don't know if the radio can turn into
anything okay so I've got the gas mask
is this you can breathe easier so it
gives unlimited stamina so I can just
run forever and ever and ever and ever
with this so that's good let's go out
got a card where you at buddy are you
here better not be here okay you're not
here okay
there's a screen right here where I can
just quickly save moving on got it hmm
that's not fun with the whole not being
able to save all the time kind of thing
and apparently I can keep this open
[Music]
and try to like listen out for anything
important whoa that's da dum up up above
humble humble
mMmmm what is that what is that oh Emily
Ross is cool with it
where the hell is Emily Ross why is this
a thing huh why do I just get this
[Music]
okay weird okay I guess this doesn't do
anything does it
Oh level four or higher damn this one
open though what was this one again [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
yeah what was this one again oh this is
the gas mask I don't know if I want this
oh no I don't want this as much as I
like that thing I don't want this uh no
I'll come back for that if I need it for
anything
well [ __ ] my dick okay here we go oh
wait no I know how to get rid of I know
wait
if I take him through the Tesla gate if
I if he follows me through the Tesla
gate then I will be in good
old-fashioned busyness okay wait
why were you so fast you're not that
fast
[Music]
I didn't want to go on the market
dimension that was so fast
why is it so fast
he got faster all right well I guess I'm
because of that save that I just did I
guess I'm stuck traversing the pocket
dimension until I get through this
okay so down one of these I think if I
remember correctly it's like you go down
oh it's so topsy-turvy and you look kind
of a little far you look down it a bit
but I don't know how far it's like SCP
that stairwell game Oh God wait huh what
the [ __ ] was that you didn't say that
who's gonna be a thing no there's
nothing down there what the [ __ ] was
that someone give me a little smooch
well torchy smooch smooch it doe J okay
one of these has like but I don't
remember which I don't remember what the
identification is for this oh okay oh
there's a note okay wait on burn no well
we got that the paper clip is not strong
enough to hold any more items well you
know oh [ __ ] okay I'm just gonna go oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no I got the
note I got the note
Oh whip the [ __ ]
Oh
oh why why are you [ __ ] you're such a
douche
you're such a douche just leave me alone
I haven't saved
oh god wham I know not this way no no
please don't kill me
no you're so fast oh you're so fast and
you're so strong oh he's so strong oh
he's so strong and so fast you got a lot
faster
I don't know anything
sucks to suck donut we're gonna it's
gonna be we're gonna load in here and
then it's the median wait Oh
peek-a-boo peek-a-boo peek-a-boo
peek-a-boo I see you I should I didn't
press the button I didn't press my
[ __ ] why did I get an achievement
take off the gas Oh so I gotta find the
note where's the note it was right up
front last time I could see better when
they had no I can't oh god it's super
wonky there's the note okay
there's the note and uh [ __ ] going
there's that and off we go dicks dicks
dicks Oh what no I don't want to go
through this again oh hello pendulum
oh I hate this
oh stop I'm not gonna fire didn't know
that was there my bad my bad my bad my
bad
Oh [ __ ] Joffrey on high Oh
so I think I think what the dealio is
once I get the note which is here once I
get the note just I just gotta like I
don't know man
wait read the note maybe I got to read
it I don't know I actually read it on my
clipboard and then wait for like Larry
to come find me cuz he was coming and
then I got out and I don't know why but
I was just gonna wait for a bit you know
just rest my legs yeah I need this note
eventually but I doubt I'm gonna get to
the point where I even need this but
it's like it's it's just
with seven for one got it bling oh I
thought Larry would have shown up by now
do I have to go on the big swinging
balls oh oh [ __ ] well please Larry don't
come back then why is that why was it
was just darkness what was that what did
I I didn't see anything it was blackness
this is a voice it's a void wait a
minute my blood
some mob am i bleeding I'm bleeding
aren't i why am i bleeding I'll just
jump okay here we go
oh god oh [ __ ] oh oh oh [ __ ]
Dom I guess I didn't leave then Oh Oh
shitty tits [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
oh it's real topsy-turvy here oh there's
nothing I vaguely remember this but I
did of all the places that they had to
revamp and make new and fun why this
place
why give Larry anything I gave Larry
anything at all nothing maybe it's a big
pillar not sure what the point of the
pillar is Oh what is that about
who's that about I'm bleeding I cook
heal heal heal
I'm calcul did I kill where am I
did I kill I think I killed oh [ __ ] I'm
in a - oh hi why the [ __ ] ways that
of all the time of all the time have
somebody in this oh hello again
that's probably
yeah I know I'm losing blood how do you
expect me to solve it
oh well I'm gonna die here that's for
sure
that's for damn sure I'm definitely
gonna die on this it's a matter of tummy
okay you can't see me mr. big eye in sky
all right mr. big I all right I think
this is where I just died straight up
oh well well I think they see me
[ __ ] look away I can't look away again
weird the odd there I'm dead no man's
land [ __ ] that was something else
la-dee-da could not do nothing couldn't
do nothing
alright so we're gonna leave that there
I don't have enough time to dive too
much deeper but I can't believe that I
just loaded up the game and saw a ton of
new [ __ ] that is pretty impressive I
haven't done that in a long time with
this game I haven't just been able to go
like I will load up the game but let's
see what happens and then do a little to
do but but for this one thanks for
watching and as always I see you in the
next video bye bye